this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 30 sitting here with Echo Charles
this is Jocko willink talking
starting off we had a topic come up
a question submitted
but it's like a a discussion topic more
than an actual
direct question are we raising soft kids
in this day and age
or is that something every generation
says
you hear about this a lot don't you what
is it the thing is strong men create
good times good times creates weak men
weak men create bad times bad times
create strong men and you get this
circle going some truth to it right
definitely some truth to it
so are we raising soft kids I think some
kids are being raised soft I think other
kids are not I think that
there is definitely a way that you could
live in this day and age where you could
be very soft as a human
you could eat foods that make you weak
you could do activities that make you
weak
you could avoid activities that would
make you strong and tough
you could avoid mental stressors that
make you mentally tough
so
I think net maybe not necessarily are we
raising
purposely but I think the environment is
will have a larger tendency right now to
make kids a little bit softer
so it's something we need to watch out
for that being said there's all you can
never take away the fact that there's
some freaking unbelievably tough kids
I'll tell you what I go down to the when
I go down to the dreams right now after
the games I'll meet young young
frog man the freaking totally legit a
hundred percent legit as legit as any
frog man I've ever met in my life young
oh what do you do I'm a machine gunner
like straight up they're ready to rock
and roll so to sit here and throw this
why we can't just throw the universal
statement out right now oh
we're raising weaker kids no go meet a
young I've I meet young Team guys
they're freaking legit yeah and you go
meet a young Marine legit
go meet a young Soldier legit so to have
this idea that
we're just universally producing weak
humans right now I think it's not true
but you can take a path at this juncture
in life where you may end up soft if
you're not careful and you may raise
soft kids if you're not careful so
that's what I think it is
environmentally the opportunity is there
to raise Wee Kids
but it is not a it is not necessarily
going to happen and some kids today also
they're smarter
there I can tell you that going through
SEAL training the kids that go through
SEAL training right now are in better
shape than the kids that I went through
Seal training with yeah because we
didn't have any program we didn't have
any supplementation we didn't have any
we didn't know about recovery we didn't
know about working out we didn't know
anything we were just just knuckle
draggers and these kids now they're
they're working they understand they
study so
from that perspective the kids are
better yeah
yeah and then you might ask well what
about the attrition rate because the
attrition rate stays the same which is
weird right so they do all these things
so I'm telling you right now the kids
and this is not just my personal opinion
this is coming from guys that I know
that work in basic SEAL training
they'll be like oh yeah the kids the
kids are in way better shape than we
were
so that's the fact but still the
attrition rate still 80 percent
why is that well
you got to push yourself a little bit
harder because you're in a boat crew now
and everyone in the boat crew the the
output is the same you see what I'm
saying so if you took a car and if you
if you and I raced and you and I both
had cars that had whatever uh 200
horsepower engines and we rolled them as
hard as we could that engine would be
tired right it would be maxed out and we
only went however fast we only went 100
miles an hour if we both had 700
horsepower engines
we would both go use every bit of it we
might go faster but we still make it
just as tired yeah
so
the they're pushing themselves harder
and and when you get to that push point
it doesn't matter how many horsepower
you have when you go a car can only hold
that whatever 90 of Max Capacity for how
long and and this is the thing a seal a
guy going through SEAL training Can Only
Hold that Max Capacity for so long and
then they quit yeah so maybe it was 80
maybe you can hold 90 for a certain
amount of time well the person that
makes it can hold 91. the person that
can hold 89 quits it doesn't matter how
many horsepower the engine is because
there's some people that end up the bet
they lose they they are the loser
they're the last place of every run the
last place of every run they're
sometimes putting out even harder than
the first place person yeah but they're
coming in last place sometimes the first
place person's putting out the same
amount as the last place person they're
both putting out 91 yeah
just just over threshold and they learn
to get over that threshold the person
that's only putting out 89 they they
someone's telling hey you got to run 91
they don't do it they go 89 and they
quit they can't keep going
so gotta watch out for that yeah and
that's not to mention that the mental um
essentially the mental part of it so you
know like you you can be and this is the
old thing too where if you're a gifted
athlete and this is this can go with
like a highly trained athlete as well
you what you're thinking as well Theory
obviously but you get to a point where
mentally you're like
you know you just cross the threshold
it's essentially not worth it oh yeah
that's what it feels like at the Mom
it's not worth it I Quit so yeah you can
be highly trained supplementation you
can be all this stuff but when you get
in there and you're hit with that thing
that pushes you over the mental
threshold when it's not worth it but
there I can I could understand I don't
know how they do it or what exactly
everything they do whatever but I could
see that has been a non-factor for the
for the the trainers or whatever being
like no no we'll push them to this
mental point I don't care how gifted
these guys are like you have to be
mentally strong no matter if you're a
fast run or a slow Runner faster swimmer
slow somewhere
it's easy to get to that point as a
trainer knowing you know what to do
let's say that you and I are both in
Seal training class and they go okay
we're gonna do bear crawls which is on
your hands feet and you're wearing your
twin 80 Illumina or twin 80 steel uh
scuba tanks
so this is just psycho right now let's
say you're let's say for this
hypothetical situation which we'll just
we'll say that you're stronger than me
so right just hypothetically which I
know it'd be hard for people to imagine
this so so you're stronger than me
and you can bear crawl with your twin
80s on your back you can bear crawl for
a hundred yards
and I am weaker than you and I can only
bear crawl for 80 yards yeah
so guess how long they're going to make
us bear crawl for they're gonna make me
bear crawl 81. they're going to make you
bear crawl 101. and there's 20 yards
difference and guess what there's
someone else
that was capable of going it doesn't
matter he could be capable of doing 110
yards guess how much he did
109 and he quit and another guy was only
capable of doing 62 yards but he only
did 61. he quit another guy was only
capable of doing 40 yards he did 41. he
stayed in he just was able to hang on
long enough yeah yeah that um can you
just suck it up and just do a little bit
more well the mental part is like if
you're not
if you don't have a mental approach and
this is again back to the my little
Theory and you know you you mentioned
little stuff every once in a while where
you're you'll say oh yeah they'll do
this thing while they'll be like hey we
push you we push you guys a little bit
too hard so we're gonna allow you guys
to rest yeah it's a unique situation and
then it's a big lie so you know get two
hours of sleep or whatever and then
right when you like fall asleep after
five minutes like wake you up and do all
this stuff like that mental those mental
things with all the physical stuff like
some people are not ready for that like
your brain is like
yeah it's weird like that and you don't
know and there's people that are
incredible athletes that ring out all
day long all day long that one that you
say um
you were JP's I think both of you guys
say this where they do a good job in
making you feel like it'll just go on
forever oh yeah like they don't say hey
one more Evolution or one more rap one
more whatever they're just like nope
again like you can feel right with that
feeling that's like almost like a
claustrophobic you know what you have to
do you have to accept death yeah like
you have to accept that oh we're gonna
be doing this log PT for actually
forever it's never gonna stop that's got
to be your mentality going into it if
you have the mentality like I could I
can just make it a little bit longer
this is going to end soon no you see me
like it's never gonna end because they
will they're looking at you
they're looking like oh wheeling's
looking tired you're looking like he
might be at his breaking point oh uh do
it again
do it again they would look at me I'd
just be like what dude oh cool watch
this doing it again
doing it again never show that little
bit of weakness so so that makes sense
yeah man yeah so I think are we raising
soft kids I think this environment you
got to be careful otherwise the kids
have a tendency to be soft let's face it
if you're looking at your social media
as a 14 year old or you're playing a
video game as a 14 year old whereas what
you would have been doing 30 years ago
would be hucking rocks at each other
yeah and sprinting around and hunting
and just getting crazy like that kid is
gonna be
I'll have a little bit more than someone
that's playing a video game or looking
at social media yeah that makes sense I
mean the whole every generation says
that I think a big part of that is true
that is true and and of course that
makes sense because the more as the
generations move on the environmental
like problems for like a better way of
putting it are become more and more
solved so like yeah you know with the
old school you look at old school like
stuff you're like bro we have machines
for that we have apps for that we have
like little gadgets to solve all those
problems never mind any of this you
press a button on this computer that you
got in your pocket and food's showing up
to your door in 30 minutes exactly right
man remember like there's like and what
else do you need water uh what do you
need anything you need is showing up
your door in an hour right so yeah that
solves a lot of problems a lot of them
you're not not out with a bow and arrow
trying to shoot a deer nope no you get
the deal you can even get grass fed oh
beef for sure versus you can be like no
I want the all-natural yeah you know you
could be like no I want my you know I
want this cow to have been eating just
grass and I want him to be less
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email
us at Jocko underground.com and we'll
get you taken care of until then we will
see you mobilized
Underground